hey everyone Ashley Carlson here I am a
massive massive Power Rangers fan we're
at the premiere tonight of the reboot
but the original cast but Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers are here tonight reuniting
in the same room for the first time in
nearly 25 years oh I'm gonna fate
original caps here reuniting for the
first time in a long long long time have
you talked have you seen everybody I've
seen everybody unfortunately I do keep
in touch with everybody yeah so it's a
tool but it's great that we're all here
together getting to experience again I'm
really good friends with a lot of the
original cast me and David Yost are like
best friends and then I talked to JT at
the lodge and I have a ps3 Austin and
forever
it's kind of incredible hopeful for the
very best together one room watching the
movie for the first time together yep
gonna be a moment there will be a moment
you five are the power range
did I just hear you say where Power
Rangers this I'm gonna joke this is your
time
[Music]
you